alors vous voyez voilà par exemple une
plaque qui a été cassé d'autres plaques
encore avec tous les morceaux que nous
avons levé
et puis la voyez la vitre cassée avec un
bonheur qu'ils ont lancé dedans les
stigmates des dégradations ne sont
presque plus visible aujourd'hui
mais la veille une dizaine de tombes du
cimetière était encore soulier des
dégradations inacceptable pour la maire
du village
c'est elle même qui a fait la triste
découverte le 2 janvier dernier
vous voyez c'est le pire qu'on a pu voir
quand je suis arrivé c'était répandu
partout les pots de fleurs retourner sur
cette tombe c'est un désastre pour moi
s'attaquer à un cimetière à s'attaquer à
des morts je pense que c'est le la pire
des choses qu'on puisse est qu'il puisse
exister
je comprends pas on se connaît tous je
ne comprends pas qu'on puisse qu'on
puisse faire des choses pareilles
de leur côté les habitants de ligny le
châtel sont eux aussi indigné par ces
dégradations
ce jour là certains sont venus vérifier
l'état des sépultures
c'est un acceptable de voir des trucs
comme ça à chaud tôt dans un endroit
comme ça et c'est malheureux de se
prendre à des gens qui sont partis par
mois au lieu de deux firmes poreux bon
moi c'est quand même dommage doit chaque
homme ce à quoi les gens qui font ça à
brancher folle et que ça combien punis
suite à ces dégradations
la mairie a déposé plainte en
gendarmerie le ou les auteurs n'ont
toujours pas été retrouvés